it is pride month everybody I saw this
video yesterday Canadian flags have been
replaced outside of the Office of Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau with yes you
guessed it the ugliest flag in the
history of humanity the Gay Pride flag
take a look
easy here live on Wellington Street
that's Parliament Hill behind me and
directly in front of me is the prime
minister's office and the privy Council
and
guess what is flying here take two
guesses here flip it around show you the
sign
here we go
Office of the Prime Minister and privy
Council
no Canadian flags at the door of the
prime minister's office at the front
door on Wellington Street
Libby what I find disturbing about this
I'm obviously for equal rights and you
can do whatever you want as an adult and
all of those stupid qualifiers that
everyone's getting tired of saying
um but to me that flag now represents a
political ideology more than let's say a
sexuality or whatever it was originally
set out to meaning it is a it is a flag
that is based in equity not equality
which is counter to most most of what
western civilization has been built upon
it's into collectivism the the long list
of leftist socialist ideas that seems a
little problematic except that's pretty
much what Justin Trudeau is all about
right
yeah Justin Trudeau fully stands for
this flag I'm surprised that he didn't
put a big old rainbow colored Maple Leaf
right in this of it and just change the
flag entirely uh but yeah this is what
he's really all about they have in
Canada he's banned conversion therapy
which means that
um you can't tell a child who claims to
have been born in the wrong body that
there's nothing wrong with their body
and they're perfectly healthy and
they're going to grow up healthy and
things will be fine
um you there's hate speech in Canada
where you can't misgender under penalty
of law you can take someone to the Human
Rights Commission for misgendering you
apparently uh yeah this is what Canada
is all about Canada is all about equity
and Justin Trudeau's ego and um you know
Pomp and uh
presentation and they don't really care
about their citizens these are the same
people that were dragging people out of
homes during covet because there were
five people in a home instead of four so
you know he makes a a big point about
equity and all of this but where
citizens are concerned their rights are
being curtailed he's pushed through a
big censorship bill for Canadian speech
online that's actually affecting a lot
of Facebook traffic and pages and things
like that so we know what Justin Trudeau
really stands for it is something much
more along the lines of authoritarian
authoritarianism political ideology and
no concern for Canadians actual ranks